let's talk about
just um
the the the match against uh dennis your
left-hand match yeah he's also
terrifying and seeing as one of the
strongest probably the
uh one of if not the strongest left hand
arm wrestler yeah um
there's a lot to be said there
maybe you could talk about this match at
a high level why did you take on this
match why did you do the left hand yeah
versus the right hand what can you tell
the story
okay
dennis the plank off
there's so much about this match i love
dennis russian guy yeah russian guy
russian i used to call him dennis
chernobyl
uh
what a monster he kind of uh
led i'd say this new era
of arm wrestling
where
the super heavyweight strength level has
just gone through the roof
i wanted the match for such a long time
we tried to get the match uh we couldn't
get it organized this is back in like
you know 2008 to 2012 couldn't get the
match couldn't get the match i've always
been more of a one-on-one puller he was
doing the uh
the tournament format i was ranked
number one in the world and towards the
end it kind of was very undecided i
ended up getting surgery
i ended up abandoning the super
heavyweight division i went down to 225s
for a few years
wal failed
temporarily
um so the 225 pound division was
scrapped and i said okay
i'm gonna go for the for the big crown
once again and i started uh to go after
super heavyweights
the
season
was
right hand
uh
i started to enter negotiations to have
the match with him i've we've been
chasing the match for 10 years
they want to do it left hand i want to
do a right hand
i just wanted to i just wanted to do the
match i wanted to do the match with
dennis i wanted to meet dennis so people
should know that you were
the right hand has always been your
strongest it has been i mean i had
surgery in 2016. i hate to make excuses
i hate to do it um
dennis was better than me that day even
on my best day if you had gone back my
entire career
at no single day do i beat dennis to
plank off in 2018. i would like to think
that i could maybe do it now
but at that point there would be no
version that could have beat him i left
all right uh right hand no
i i'm curious about the right uh but
left hand so is the world
well it might still happen it might but
uh
dennis
completely destroyed me
um
and
i learned a lot from it
i i think before
the dennis match
i think i was i don't know i i don't
know exactly what your word to use
maybe i felt like
my thinking was a little bit elitist
uh and
i really learned a lot i was really
humbled that day
[Music]
by how far and how professional and how
prepared dennis was
and how seriously he took the sport
there's a mental
a slightly terrifying
calmness to him
which only comes with extreme
preparation i think yeah his level of
dedication
uh was extremely inspiring to me um
you know
i
used to do a job
where
it was serious enough that the the price
could be death right
and
i arm wrestled throughout that entire
period
and i always kind of
looked at uh
you know the cost
of doing an activity being death
uh
limited to
soldiering
and
i i kind of changed my mind a lot after
that match i realized that
anything that you're in love with
once you get far enough down the road
and professional enough at it it's gonna
kill you
like doesn't matter what you're doing if
you're crazy enough about anything it's
probably gonna take your life for me in
some way
and that doesn't mean you rush towards
death it's just your level of investment
and level of risk
can have some catastrophic effects
buckowski charles bukowski i think has
the quote uh
do what you love and let it kill you
right like that right
and
i understood
that dennis's level of professionalism
far exceeded mine
in
what we were doing at the time
and i realized that you know
i i was no longer employed i was
now in the world of professional arm
wrestling
and i realized that uh you know what was
i doing
like how serious was i
so dennis is an incredible guy
is there moments in that match there's
there's humility there too from him
that was a fascinating
uh sort of
it it seemed like you realized that you
just hit a wall and you were not ready
enough for it it was incredible
there was so many things that i remember
about the dentist match i mean i
remember
you know
seeing video of somebody and then
meeting them in person it's different
i remember in the weigh-ins sorry not
the weigh-ins and the standoff that we
did you know before the match i'm
looking at him like i'm i'm close i'm
looking at his arms
and
his bicep
it looked like an ass
like it was like a freaking glute muscle
yeah like his
entire structure was so sinewy and
just so strong
i was like wow he's so physically so
impressive
and
i remember when i arm wrestled him
a certain at a certain time
he allowed me to kind of set my position
you can very
you can't really tell because it happens
very quickly
but he let me set my position which
means i kind of got my locks in where
you can kind of really do a great hold
and he just ripped through me
just so you you were able to get this
great position so it was
tore right through me
yeah and uh
the first time i ever thought that uh
you know he that i had torn something i
thought like after the match i'm like
did he rip my chest right in half like
um
wha what what did it no it's 100 yes no
i didn't i didn't actually nothing went
purple or anything but uh
yeah the strength gap was very
significant with dennis uh so could he
what would it take to beat him on that
day um
it would it would take me just being
a little bit stronger
um more and more healthy yeah
my left was not as healthy as it should
be
like i didn't have a full rounded
technical arsenal
it takes a time after surgery it really
does like i mean
you can be good but
after a surgery like what i had you know
you're probably looking at three or four
years before you're starting to hit
technical proficiency the way you should
be
and uh yeah just a bit stronger
how do you interpret the calmness on his
face well what is that about
is he actually it's very russian it's a
russian it's a russian thing i think i
don't know i see a lot of russians like
that you know they're so like stoic and
i'm such a fan of russia i i really want
to go to moscow i've been saying it
forever you've never been not yet not
yet i want to go i want to just go and
live there for like a month and just
train the moscow's got such a crazy arm
wrestling scene
they've got from what i understand they
just have so many clubs there's so many
strong athletes
this go and just
lightning rod
yeah are you considered doing
something of that sort it's like rocky
iv again oh yeah like oh and lead up to
june i would certainly consider it i've
got
only one trip planned at the moment
administration is very important
what do you mean by administration so
like managing your time and management
yeah the management has to be very
efficient
you know when i'm a tourist when i'm a
visitor a little bit of that goes down
you know when i'm at my home and things
are familiar
i've got a really great grasp on my time
you know everything's in place
everything's perfect you know
if i could magically transport moscow
into my hometown and just go out and
visit them
yeah so it's very difficult when you're
traveling you have to keep all the you
have to uh figure out what you're eating
where how are you getting the food all
the socializing plus you're
more and more a celebrity so there's
social interaction which i don't know um
how draining that could be on you
outside of the arm wrestling table so
i'll you have to manage all of that
because
ultimately you have to focus on
the fight ahead
yeah
yeah a lot of my strength comes from
just being in a familiar place
doing my routine
i love to travel i love to get out there
and meet people and
new experiences
but when i just want to really prepare
for a big match yeah home is uh
where i get strong so that loss against
dennis was one of the few losses in your
career
uh how did that
feel
in the moments after in the days after
in the months after in the years after
how has it changed you
as an arm wrestler as a human being
well
it's tough to lose uh
still haunt you
um
[Music]
i don't think so i actually was really
happy to lose to dennis
because you know sometimes when you lose
a match there's a lot of matches that
i've lost where they upset me because i
know i made a mistake
i didn't make a mistake with dennis he
was just he was just way better there's
nothing i could have done that day uh
i'm really at peace with it um
dennis
to me was just a big inspiration i think
that me arm wrestling dennis left-handed
that day just let me touch probably one
of the strongest human beings on the arm
wrestling table that's ever lived you
know left-handed
so so knowing that's possible
is almost like
yeah uh inspiration to you that i can be
at that level too yeah
yeah yeah i'm seeing what dennis did
uh you know just trying to absorb a
little bit of his knowledge uh
planted seeds in me
yeah i mean when i look at my career
it's it's a bit like the stock market
but
for sure i'm trending upwards
and
since
really kind of wrapping my mind around
some of the russian philosophies
they really changed my training systems
uh there were some base philosophies
that they talked to me about over there
that
massively impacted my training is it
possible to convert some of those
philosophies into words can you describe
some of the ideas they taught you
so never smile
right
man there's so like it takes a while to
break the ice with a lot of these guys
uh well once you do i mean that's this
deepest bonds you can form there yeah
yeah for sure
i think that i was raised under
i believe it's a flawed it's i mean it's
not flawed because it has its value as
well
but it's best if you understand both
philosophies
i think a north american thing
that's just so ingrained in our fitness
society
is no pain no gain you know and just
pushing and like sweating and going
harder and like fighting through like
and grit and toughness and
but
and then you talk to the russians and
they're like yeah never fail you never
fail never never go to failure uh always
feel good
always feel good it should always feel
good don't
um
and those two philosophies express
themselves very differently um
and if you want to get strong
yeah don't fail
don't fail
so
that's how you they also are believers
of volume
yeah uh
there's a lot of strategies but yeah
volume is a massive principle and volume
is very hard to achieve when you're
believing in no pain no gain right right
they don't really go together no pain no
gain more injuries
so the is there parallels because in in
wrestling some of the greatest wrestlers
of all time are russian and they they
were big um dan gable talks about it
they were big on
play right like lighter wrestling right
probably ultimately actually it boils
down to that's how you achieve higher
volume right like over the stretch of
years
the way to reduce injury
um i mean in wrestling also technique
might um
have greater value than it does in arm
wrestling obviously technique is
extremely important in arm wrestling but
power is
like can defeat technique
it seems like yeah in wrestling you can
get away
there's a lot of ways you can really uh
uh do sneak attacks sort of use leverage
all those kinds of things so there's
even more incentive to do play and all
that kind of stuff yeah but uh
do you see the parallels between the two
worlds oh yeah wrestling and arm
wrestling 100
you saw what i did the other night
right so i'm playing on the table for
hours yeah right so that's that's that's
that's my number one
training thing that i do is i go on the
table for hours and i play
yeah
yeah when you did uh sergey can you pull
up that video it's on devin's channel
the uh the water tank one oh it's like
180 p it's like
the wi-fi in there was so bad yeah it's
great i love it but it's uh maybe the
i don't know if it was fisheye but it
had a fisheye feels yeah crowded i mean
so much camaraderie it was it was
amazing but maybe uh
just a brief mention of uh dimitri the
uh the russian
the russian guy what uh
uh
what in that play what are some
memorable things here like when you when
you go against a bunch of different
people a bunch of strangers what are all
the differences and how do you grow from
them how do you learn from them well
everybody's a bit different so
i love to go to new clubs because the
energy's always high
like the first time you go to a club
everybody's trying to kill you yeah yeah
so there's excitement yeah
and so you feed off of that yeah you do
you can you can if you're able to be
strong enough to absorb it without
injury it's awesome it's awesome
um because they're giving you everything
they can yeah
yeah
right so it's it's very specific right
like i'm gonna get way stronger at arm
wrestling and what i try and do
when i go to these places is i make an
assumption
i make an assumption that i'm the best
guy there
and so i'll arm wrestle in a way that
kind of protects them because the more i
can protect them
and kind of keep them kind of in a good
position
they can actually give me more
right so i kind of i kind of give them
little pieces that i think will put them
in a place that they can really give me
more
and so yeah that's what i'm doing and
then when i see somebody like dimitri
yeah i pull that in a little bit right
so okay so i know dimitri's the number
one guy in texas
uh you know lots of respect to the guy i
i won't give him all the pieces until i
really kind of gauge where he's at
because i certainly in training don't
want to fail
i don't want that i don't want to
when you fail in arm wrestling it's just
imagine it's just bad technique
and you're trying and bad technique
you're going to get hurt
yeah so you always want to be in a
strong position here what about in how
do how does endurance come into play
here and here's video yeah strapping up
that's right
yeah how do you i mean you went for like
i don't know two hours yeah it was long
so the first this first run of the video
i think was a little over an hour and
then i took a break and i probably did
another 45 minutes or so but
i mean do you
how can
are you okay
with the endurance aspect of this yeah
that's probably like when you talk to
the arm wrestling world that's probably
what i'm best known for is is my
endurance so this helps build that
it does but that's not why i'm doing it
i'm doing it to get strong
in my opinion this is this is one of the
best ways to get strong especially far
away from the from a tournament uh or or
any kind of an event
uh
i wouldn't want to do this
you know even a month or even six weeks
or even maybe even eight weeks before a
big event i'd want to already be kind of
shrinking my volume
but
far away from an event yeah as much
volume as your body can handle and
you'll feel it you'll feel it like i
felt it at times like you know after the
hour mark i'm like okay i can feel my
blood sugar kind of diminishing i can
feel like the blood that's going through
my muscles is kind of like
it's not really pushing more good stuff
in it i'm starting to break down and you
don't want that
you don't want that
you